hello everyone and welcome to the
biggest ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll and this is
the first substantive edition of the
biggest ideas we had an introduction of
course but today our first ever idea
which is going to be conservation this
is not conservation in the sense that an
ecologist would care about we're not
conserving the wilderness or the forest
or the environment or anything like that
we're talking about conservation laws in
physics especially my favorite
conservation of momentum there'll be
others we'll talk about conservation of
energy a little bit electric charge and
so forth but momentum I think is really
the crucial one now that's a strange
idiosyncratic choice I think that if a
lot of people a lot of professional
physicists were making video series
about the biggest ideas in physics they
wouldn't necessarily start with
conservation of momentum we all know
it's an important idea if you took
physics in high school or college you
probably gives little problems where
balls bump into each other and you had
to solve for their motion using
conservation of momentum but I want to
go a little bit further than that I want
to think that the idea of conservation
of momentum really was the transition
from pre-modern to modern physics where
I'm putting that transition around the
time of Galileo and Newton not you know
quantum mechanics and relativity but
what we now think of as physics really
came to be only once we understood
conservation of momentum that's a kind
of a grandiose claim so I won't have to
back it up a little bit but it gives us
an inroad into what physics actually is
so to do this to make this claim we're
gonna have to do a little bit of history
and I'll be honest you know physicists
are not very good at doing history we
have stories that we tell each other
about this or that anecdote in the
history of physics but sometimes maybe
more often than not those anecdotes are
not a hundred percent accurate certainly
they don't convey all the nuances of
what was really going on and I'm not any
different I'm not claiming in any way to
be a true historian of science but I
haven't been able to find really very
much about the true history of
conservation of momentum I think if you
believe the case I'm gonna make here you
will
agree with me that it is absolutely
crucial to what physics is as we
currently practice it so this is a great
project out there for somebody for some
historian of science to really trace
through the history of conservation of
momentum what I'm gonna do is more the
standard physicist thing of telling a
few individual stories pretending that
they fit together to form a rational
complete whole and for that purpose we
might as well start with Aristotle
Aristotle is I think you know the first
great figure in the history of physics
and let me pause to digress a little bit
about Aristotle and Plato and the other
ancient Greeks because sometimes they
get a bad rap among modern scientists no
less a personage than Bertrand Russell
tells a story about Aristotle which is
wholly misleading I think and truly
unfair there's the idea that somehow
before modern physics came along before
the Scientific Revolution philosophers
didn't understand that in order to
understand the world you had to look at
it they had this idea which some people
still had today that you could figure
out the world just by thinking about it
and I think that for Plato that might
have been somewhat fair accusation but
for Aristotle it certainly was not he
was absolutely an empiricist at heart
and the story that Bertrand Russell
tells is about Aristotle's perspective
on the number of teeth that people have
Aristotle said very explicitly that men
and women human beings have different
numbers of teeth and Bertrand Russell
made fun of him for saying that didn't
he just like open his wife's mouth and
look at the number of teeth but I think
that if you actually read what Aristotle
wrote that is an entirely unfair
characterization if you read the section
where Aristotle was talking about teeth
he says you know this set of species has
this number of teeth etc these other
species we don't know about yet because
we haven't looked he was being very good
empiricist but the point is it's hard
sometimes to put ourselves in the shoes
in the conceptual framework of thinkers
who lived a long time before us I mean
Aristotle is circa 400 BCE before Common
Era
that's what historians in classes
to use rather than just bc because they
don't want to be religious about it so
for centuries before the Common Era
started Aristotle is trying his best to
understand the number of teeth the
different people have so of course he
did look but there's obstacles to
looking mostly modern dental hygiene had
not been invented yet it's quite likely
that a lot of people didn't have the
same number of teeth when they were
adults that they had when they were
children also even in perfectly healthy
adults the number of teeth is not
necessarily constant wisdom teeth can
come in very late so if you want to
criticize Aristotle criticize him
because he made a mistake his data were
incorrect but he thought that the data
said that men and women had different
numbers of teeth the same is true for
Aristotle's view on motion which is why
we're actually here I mean let's think
about what physics is aerosol wrote a
whole big book called physics and what
physics is has not changed that much
since Aristotle's time it's the study of
the stuff of which the universe is made
and how that stuff changes how it
transforms how it interacts when time
passes what happens to that stuff in the
universe that's basically what physics
is these days we have a much more
nuanced and technical notion of what
stuff is and what changes etc but the
goal is basically the same so when
Aristotle was trying to understand
change in motion he would look at the
world right and so let me draw a little
picture of the world this is the surface
of the earth and here's a box on the
surface of the earth okay Harris tall
looks at a box like that I could have
drawn a rock but I'm not very good at
drawing the same rock more than once so
here is a box
Aristotle sees it it's just sitting
there the box isn't doing anything it's
not moving and if you let it to its own
devices it would not spontaneously start
moving but you could started moving by
pushing it so if a person comes along
and pushes the box then you can get some
motion in the direction of the push but
then our solid goes on to also notice if
you stopped pushing it so the person
lets the box go guess what
box comes to rest again and he sees
things like this happened in many many
different contexts remember ancient
Greece they didn't know about the
periodic table or modern material
science so they spoke a language of
earth wind fire and water and Aristotle
says things that have a lot of fire in
them naturally go up things that have a
lot of earth in them naturally go down
and this is a clue to how Aristotle
thought about things not just the
direction in which they move but the
idea that there were natures
there was something that it was kind of
like a purpose or a want or a desire on
the part of these objects there was a
state of being that they found most
comfortable and they settled into them
and stayed there so as you probably know
Aristotle actually took this logic and
built it up to a proof for the existence
of God he said look in order to get
things to move you need something to
move them you need something to push
them and whatever that thing pushing is
needs something to make it move
something to move it to push it and
you're not allowed says Aristotle to
have this chain of movers go back
infinitely far therefore there must be
an initial unmoved mover which he
identified with God now you can quibble
with this argument in all sorts of
directions for example why not have an
infinite chained up movers but today we
have another much more important much
more profound objection to Aristotle's
argument and in this lecture this this
little story that I'm telling is not
about God it's about how we think about
how the world works a shift from a story
of nature's and purposes to one of
patterns and in fact equations that tell
you how the world moves so the next guy
on the scene in my story I'm skipping
over some stories is uh eben cena even
cena was a persian polymath he lived in
the Islamic Golden Age so circa 1000
Common Era see and so he's a very
annoying person if you're a theoretical
physicist even seeing that his his name
is often latinized too of a Senna so you
might
under that rubric so mostly
what even Cena did for a living was he
was a doctor and he was a scholar and so
he studied health and biology and
physiology and things like that he wrote
politically about these subjects but he
would also do physics sort of in his
spare time right on weekends and at
night and in doing physics he managed to
come up with this wonderful principle
that we now know as conservation of
momentum that's a little bit unfair
that's giving even seen a little bit too
much credit because conservation of
momentum in the modern sense of things
is something very specific and
mathematical and quantitative he didn't
have equations for it but what he did
was you know he looked back at one of
the issues that Aristotle had so
Aristotle knew that there were examples
because he wasn't empiricist easy to
observe things he knew that we we all
know of examples where things don't seem
to come to a halt at least very quickly
so consider an arrow flying through the
air there's a warlike time back then
people knew about arrows flying through
the air so here's an arrow flying
through the air and you can shoot the
arrow and didn't go a long way before
stopping it will go up and down but it's
horizontal speed doesn't seem to change
that much in apparent contradiction to
Aristotle's idea that something won't
move unless there's something else
moving it so Aristotle came up with a
complicated story according to which the
air in front of the arrow was displaced
by the arrow moving into it and then
that air moved around to the back and
exerted a force as we would now say it
pushed the arrow so there was something
there was that arrow wanted to slow down
but the air behind it kept pushing it
whereas the Box on the ground the ground
does not move around and keep pushing it
this is Aristotle's explanation for why
the arrow can go a long way now it's not
a very good explanation I think probably
Aristotle himself was a little wary of
pushing this too hard even Cena didn't
fall for he's like no no that's not what
would happen what he said instead is
that
without air resistance if you could
imagine something that was moving in the
vacuum when there's no snow stuff there
to slow it down motion continues at a
constant velocity that was even seen as
insight now again I'm not a super expert
on the history here so what I believe is
true from my meager reading is that even
c-note was not making this argument in
order to say therefore the natural state
of things is to keep moving at a
constant velocity what he said was and
of course motion does not continue
therefore there's no such thing as the
vacuum he was trying to argue against
the existence of what we would now call
empty space of course these days we know
we have a very good approximation to the
vacuum we even have spaceships like
Voyager over here that fly through the
vacuum more or less at a constant
velocity not exactly because there's
outgassing they're still in the
gravitational field of the Sun and other
things in the galaxy but more or less
constant velocity to the vacuum is
actually what happens but I want to give
even Cena credit here for this idea that
you didn't necessarily conceptually need
something to be pushing to get something
to move and that idea was really
developed into a more modern perspective
by Galileo circa 1600 Galileo I think
was really the first one to say no
actually the natural state of things
that do not have any external influences
acting on them is to move in straight
lines at a constant velocity again even
he didn't have things exactly right he
thought that there was sort of a
circular kind of natural motion and the
linear kind of natural motion but okay
we're gonna give him credit for this
really important idea that if you didn't
act on something that was moving in a
straight line it would just keep doing
it and then of course Isaac Newton was
the one who really got it right
in modern terms and his great master
work the principia mathematica was from
1687 I think and that's where he
basically wrote down what we now knows
Newton's laws of motion 1687 right yes
it is on my notes here that's what it
says so Newton's laws of motion there's
three laws and the very first law is
something that is moving in a straight
line that has no forces acting on it is
just going to continue moving in that
straight line until something does act
on it and then the second law which is
the one that is all the work when you
solve the equations and do your physics
homework problems is the one that says
when you do act on it here's how the
thing accelerates acceleration being a
deviation from motion at constant
velocity so Newton had the whole shebang
there but so there's there's good news
and bad news here in terms of what they
understood Galileo and Newton Galileo
and Newton appreciated that things that
kept moved things that were moving at a
constant velocity would just keep moving
okay
they didn't quite have the words like
momentum and energy they certainly
didn't have any systematic understanding
of what was conserved so conserved means
there is some property it's not a kind
of stuff right like momentum is not a
fluid you know you don't hand someone
some momentum or some energy or
something like that you hand them some
stuff and the momentum or the energy is
a characteristic it's a property given
the stuff and what it's doing we can
calculate an equation which will tell us
how much momentum it has how much energy
it has and so forth but Galileo and
Newton didn't really understand the
differences between momentum and energy
and all those things
even though Newton had the equations to
do it so in Newtonian mechanics we don't
just say things move at a constant
velocity we can actually define momentum
quantitatively its mass times velocity
MV if you want to do it symbolically
whereas there is kinetic energy which is
a different thing which is also
conserved in straight-line motion
and that is 1/2 mass times velocity
squared 1/2 MV squared so obviously if
the mass is constant and the velocity is
constant both of these things are
conserved the question the hard question
is are either one of them or both of
them conserved really all the time if
you count all the things interacting
with everything else in the universe so
it turns out that conservation of
momentum is kind of easier to see than
conservation of energy so kinetic energy
by itself is just not conserved when
things interact with each other because
energy can take different forms and
convert from one form to another while
the total amount of energy is still
conserved that's why it actually tends
it tends to be harder to show
empirically that energy is conserved
because you might not be sure that
you've listed all the different forms
that energy can have so the classic
example that's given in physics classes
is elastic versus inelastic collisions
an elastic collision is one where both
momentum and energy kinetic energy are
explicitly conserved so think about two
billiard balls bouncing into each other
billiard ball billiard ball they come
into each other they smack off and they
go in some different direction in the
approximation where the there's no sound
no noise no dissipation both the total
momentum and the total kinetic energy
are conserved in an elastic collision
but we also have inelastic collisions
and that that's sort of what you might
guess an inelastic collision is one in
which you can't say things like well
there's no noise there's no friction or
anything like that so let's imagine two
balls of silly putty that come in to
each other and they smack together to
form a bigger ball of silly putty in the
middle okay you could calculate the
momentum of each ball of silly putty
beforehand it's a vector quantity to be
technical about it and they could smack
together and you could calculate the
momentum of the total big ball and it
would be the same
momentum is conserved in this kind of
collision but the kinetic energy is not
kinetic energy is just a vector you just
add it together and it might be that if
you had two equal mass balls of silly
putty moving at the same velocity they
would come together smack into each
other and just stop their velocity we go
from two nonzero numbers to one number
that was equal to zero clearly the
number that we call one-half MV squared
the kinetic energy has changed so what
has happened all that's happened is that
the energy that was kinetic turned into
some other kind of energy right it took
energy to deform the silly putty it got
twisted and it in fact would heat up a
little bit in that process so really
both energy and momentum are conserved
but it's easier to see that momentum is
conserved the person who figured this
out was actually Emily du Chatelet and
she was circa 1740 I think so Emily du
Chatelet translated Newton's Principia
into French now to be honest I'm not
sure that she translated from the
original Latin or from an English
translation but she knew the math she in
fact went beyond what Newton had done
and analyzed his equations and she
figured out that you could do an
experiment she thinks she's the one who
figured out that you know both momentum
and energy are conserved under the right
circumstances again I don't know the
history very very well but what it came
down to was dropping objects onto a
surface that could deform and sort of
absorb the energy so like a clay surface
or something like that rather than a
cement surface and then you could show
that the amount of deformation depended
on 1/2 MV squared on the energy that was
contained there in the falling object so
she's the one who showed that both
momentum and energy are conserved
they're not the only ones there are
other things that are conserved electric
charge is conserved right we are made of
electrons protons and neutrons neutrons
have zero electric charge protons are +1
electrons or -1 so you will never see
for example a proton turning into an
electron that would violate the
conservation of charge of course would
also violate conservation of energy also
but what you can see is a neutron
turning into an electron and a proton
and an anti-neutrino so neutrons charge
zero protons charge +1 electrons charge
-1 neutrinos or anti neutrinos charge 0
so one Neutron can turn into a proton
and electron and an anti-neutrino
conserving both energy and charge at the
same time so this is a big deal ok this
idea of conservation laws there's no
conservation laws in Aristotelian
physics in Aristotle you know if you
come across that box sitting on the
ground and you say well what conserved
quantities are there you don't know
there there aren't any it may have been
moving right it may have had energy or
momentum before but it came to arrest
and we don't know what its past was just
from its current perspective whereas if
you believe in these conservation laws
then you shift your perspective from a
story of nature's and teleology goals
purposes favorite things to do to a
story of patterns to a story that says
given that the universe is doing one
thing now I can predict what it will do
next and I can also infer what it was
doing just one second ago this idea
really didn't even come from Newton or
Galileo it came from pierre-simon
laplace Laplace one of my favorite
mathematicians and physicists he was
circa 1800 and Laplace came up with the
famous Laplace's demon thought
experiment Laplace says imagine I have a
vast intelligence that is so smart it
knows the position and the velocity of
every particle or every bit of stuff
everywhere in the universe and then
furthermore it has enormous
calculational capacities so we can solve
Newton law Newton's laws to that vast
intelligence which was later dubbed
Laplace's team and he never called it a
demon
applause is diamond did that best
intelligence laplace says the future and
the past are as fixed and known as the
present moment is that would not have
been a feature of Aristotelian physics
this is something new and there's no
place in that story for purposes or
nature's what there is is a rule a set
of rules which we call the laws of
physics which say given what's happening
at one moment we know what will happen
toward the future and we know what did
happen in the past
now of course modern physics is gonna
mess this up a little bit it's not that
it went away but it becomes more subtle
and complicating we will talk about that
in future episodes future big ideas that
we'll get to but the shift in
perspective lingers on and I think is
the important thing here the the
universe is sort of a mechanism this was
called the clockwork universe right that
is what they actually referred to it as
it's the universe is no longer in this
perspective alive the universe just is
obeying rules so a new problem arises
how do we understand ourselves as living
beings in this universe which is not
itself alive this is why I would say the
conservation of momentum was really the
transition from pre-modern to modern
physics of course there's a lot more
that went on than that but it's a whole
shift of how we think about what the
universe is which is why I'm giving
pride of place to conservation of
momentum as the first idea that we're
talking about here in this Big Ideas
series now we don't let you go one just
yet I want to talk about one more
ramification of this idea if we go back
to even Cina if we go back to the idea
well if you ignored air resistance then
things would move at a constant velocity
what if you know even Xena had gone back
to Aristotle what if he had had a time
machine he'd gone back 1,400 years and
he'd said look your mistake is if you
ignore air resistance things actually
move at the constant velocity
Aristotle I think would have been
entirely within his rights to say but
there is
assistance he should I ignore it that
sounds like a bad idea right like a
resistance exists in the world he's an
empiricist he wants to describe the
actual world not some made-up crazy
thought experiment world so why is it
that we base modern physics on this
idealized world rather than the actual
world in which people like Aristotle
lived so the the short way of saying
this is the idea of the spherical cow
this is from an old joke that physicists
tell each other
a farmer asks for advice from a
physicists about how to maximize the
milk output of his herd of cows
physicist goes off and thinks about it
and then comes back few days later and
says ok I've got it all figured out
first assume a spherical cow now to a
farmer that does not sound like a very
good idea a spherical cow right like
cows are not anywhere near spherical
that is a bad approximation but to a
physicist it makes perfect sense because
that's how physics works by stripping
away all the complications we're very
proud of our spherical cow abilities let
me show you this is actually an award
that I won this is a prize given by the
graduate students at the University of
Chicago is a teaching award and it's a
spherical cow award get it see the
spherical cow the point is the spherical
cow philosophy takes us really far this
is a special thing about physics that
wouldn't be true typically in biology or
farming or psychology or political
science or economics or anything like
that
the idea that we can ignore hugely
important features of the world get an
answer in a dramatically simplified
context and then add back in the rest of
the world is sort of a small correction
right the true nature of motion is to
move and conserve momentum and then you
add in air resistance and friction and
dissipation and you can get the right
answer that is a technique that works in
a wide variety of physics circumstances
that just often isn't available when
objects in the world are really talking
to each other varies
strongly now there's areas of physics
nonlinear dynamics and other areas where
objects do talk to each other very
strongly and you could not ignore the
interactions but for much of physics the
spherical cal approximation works pretty
well not only did the invention of
conservation of momentum mark a shift
from a vocabulary of nature's and
purposes to a vocabulary of patterns and
equations it also marked the
introduction of this spherical cow
philosophy that works so well it's why
if you sort of turn it on its head a
little bit
why does physics seem hard because
physics is easy that's the answer
because in physics we can make these
hilariously inaccurate idealizations and
approximations and still learn something
in a way that in other areas of science
we can't this has allowed us to think
about individual electrons and atoms and
things like that and make enormous
progress on the basis of those thoughts
that's why physics is hard because
physics is so easy that we've learned an
enormous amount about it it's not that
the nature of physics is hard
the only thing hard about is we've
learned a lot it's just so much easier
to make progress in physics than it is
in economics or biology or even
chemistry or astronomy and things like
that this is why I think it makes
perfect sense to start the series on the
biggest ideas in the universe with
conservation of momentum and the
spherical cow philosophy it's that kind
of point of view that is going to lead
us to a lot more really big ideas